at seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
wayne cousins the police officer charged
with the kidnap and murder of sarah
everard is due to appear at
westminster magistrates court this
morning
discussions continue over whether a
vigil planned in sarah's memory can go
ahead
after officers confirm a body found in
woodland in kent is that of the 33 year
old
i didn't want to leave i didn't want to
leave my room at night i felt this
person was a predator
moved to speak out the woman whose
attacker went on to kill
tells us why women feel let down by the
criminal justice system
the city of minneapolis pays a 27
million
settlement to the family of george floyd
over his killing in police custody
but campaigners say a criminal
conviction is needed
lost at sea the families raising money
to try to find
three fishermen who went missing more
than six weeks ago
it's just horrible waiting and you're
longing for it
you're just longing for them to say look
we found them
breeding the perfect pup we'll hear from
the researchers
trying to understand what makes the best
possible guide dog
in a sport lee westwood shows the
youngsters how to do it as rory mcilroy
misses the cut
at golf's players championship
[Music]
and we've seen some very wet weather
crossing the country overnight it's
giving way to
showers but there's still quite a
blustery and rather cool picture things
do start to
improve into next week with the look at
the weather a little later on
and at quarter to eight we'll take a
look at the newspapers with the comedian
andrew doyle and journalist and
broadcaster badisha
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast wayne cousins a serving member
of the metropolitan police service is
due to appear at westminster magistrates
court this morning
charged with the kidnap and murder of
sarah everard
ms everard who was 33 disappeared while
walking home from a friend's house in
south london
last week yesterday officers
investigating the case confirmed a body
found in woodland in kent
is hers the events have led to an
outpouring of anger
about women's safety on britain's
streets organisers of a vigil for miss
everard in london say they're continuing
talks with the metropolitan police
to work out if the event can go ahead
this evening i'm affairs correspondent
mark white
reports on london's clapham common last
night the met police commissioner
visited the area where sarah everard was
last seen
crested a dick reassuring and
understandably anxious public
that there will be extra police patrols
here in the days ahead
this is a few miles away at scotland
yard her assistant commissioner
confirmed the main suspect in sarah's
alleged abduction
and murder had been charged that man
pc wayne cousins a serving armed police
officer
with the mets parliamentary and
diplomatic command
the news of the criminal charges was
relayed to the family of sarah everard
by the same specialist officers who just
hours earlier
had confirmed that the human remains
found in woods near
ashford and kent were those of sarah
at the suspect's house in the kent town
of deal
forensics teams are still conducting a
detailed examination of his property
groups of others have been involved in
fingertip searches
of land near the house and around a
garage in dover
the suspect's former family business
the sense of profound shock and wider
debate over women's safety
has triggered a number of protests and
vigils
the prime minister said he shared that
sense of outrage
i can see and i totally understand
why this has triggered such a wave of
feeling
on on this issue on the issue of safety
of women
and safety of the of the streets and i i
want to echo
very much what pretty patel said uh
which is that no
woman should walk our streets in fear
every woman
should feel able to walk our streets in
safety
wayne cousins is due to appear at
westminster magistrates court today
as scotland yard confirmed he was taken
to hospital for a second time
in as many days after he sustained
another head injury
in his police cell he's now back in
police custody
mark white sky news
organizers of a vigil planned in london
this evening in memory of sarah everard
say they're continuing discussions with
the met police about whether the event
can go ahead the reclaimed these streets
event on clapham common was thrown into
doubt
after scotland yard warned the gathering
would breach coronavirus regulations
the organizers mounted an appeal at the
high court but the judge refused to
intervene
similar events were set to take place
across the uk at 6 pm tonight but some
have been cancelled
in light of the police stance while
others are moving online
sarah everard's death has prompted many
women to speak out against the
harassment they've suffered
but from unwanted touching to domestic
violence and rape
very few crimes committed against women
end in a conviction
a victim of the man who went on to
murder the student libby squires has
described for the very first time
how she felt failed by the police she
spoke to katarina vertotsi
a warning her story includes details of
sexual crimes that some people
may find upsetting she's never spoken
publicly about this before but in 2017
as a student this young woman was in her
ground floor bedroom
and saw a man pressed up against her
window
looking in our first thought was maybe
it would have been an opportunistic sort
of burglar
maybe it'd support the keys but when my
housemate came back from work at local
bar
around 4 am she found a used condom and
stained pair of women's knickers on the
door handle
it was only really sort of afterwards
that this sort of fear really set in
i felt this person was a predator but
you know at that time it was just a
hunch
you know even my own friends and family
thought i was overreacting
at first she says she felt the police
didn't take her report
seriously and yet the perpetrator was
later identified as pavel relevitch
by then he'd raped and killed 21 year
old student libby squire
in a random attack as she was coming
home from a night out this man
had not only you know violated a lot a
number of young women in the area but
then got on to do something
you know just unimaginably horrific
homicide police's internal inquiry into
their handling of the pavel rolovich
investigation found that the force did
the best they could with the information
they had
at the time but campaigners say women
across the country are being let down
especially when it comes to gender-based
violence and sexual offences
the figures show the prevalence of
sexual assault hasn't changed
significantly
in a decade more women are victims they
are four times more likely than men to
have experienced sexual assault
most common is unwanted touching
followed by indecent exposure
but fewer than one in five victims of
rape or assault by penetration
reported their experience to police with
embarrassment the most common reason for
non-reporting
followed by thinking the police couldn't
help
the police are working to try and change
this but for some victims of
gender-based crime it's already too late
marie mccourt's daughter helen was 22
when she was abducted and murdered
just minutes from home when it's murder
we don't know what damage they did to
our children
we don't know how much pain they were in
when their life was taken it's
it's like if somebody comes and punches
a
hole in your heart campaigners want
better legislation against
minor sexual or harassment offences to
stop perpetrators progressing
to something potentially worse until
then they say
victims are bearing the burden i wish i
could have stopped him
like you know i wish i could have known
in that moment and gone bolting down
that street and
not that i could have done anything
katarina vertotsi sky news
across your mind the u.s city of
minneapolis has agreed to pay the family
of george floyd
27 million dollars to settle a civil
lawsuit
mr floyd was killed last year after a
police officer pressed his knee against
his neck for nearly nine minutes
sparking worldwide protests the civil
dispute is separate from the ongoing
criminal trial
where police officer derek chauvin is
charged with third
and second degree murder as well as
manslaughter sally lockwood reports
george floyd's death sparked protest
around the world
but ten months on the anger has turned
to apprehension
will change and justice come
as the criminal trial begins the civil
lawsuit concludes
with a record payout from the city of
minneapolis
to the floyd family the settlement
is not just historic because
of the 27 million dollars
paid out but for the impact
on social justice policy reforms
and police reforms the next chapter in
their fight for justice
is here former officer derek shovin is
on
trial for murder in the fortified
courthouse
but there's a deep mistrust among some
not just for police but for the system
already critical the jury selection is
too white
and concerned a payout isn't justice
without a conviction
so it really is a significant settlement
and it's a
significant indictment of the way that
police have treated african-american
people in this country for a very long
time
so i you know for that standpoint it's
significant
but um beyond that we really do have to
have
a conviction in the case of derek
chauvin we really need that because
otherwise the only people who will have
had a consequence
for this killing will be george floyd
himself and the taxpayers
how confident are you that you will get
that conviction
frankly i'm concerned exactly a year on
the family of brianna taylor
still don't feel they have justice shot
dead in a flawed police raid of her home
in louisville
her family received a payout but no
accountability for her killing
their deaths may have been a reckoning
for racial inequity
but for many only a conviction will feel
like change
sally lockwood sky news new york
the prime minister is backing a national
day of reflection to mark the
anniversary of the first coronavirus
lockdown on the 23rd of march
the charity marikuri is planning the day
to remember those who
died during the pandemic it marks a year
to the day when boris johnson first told
uk residents they must stay at home
in an effort to limit the spread of
covet 19. there'll be a minute silence
at 12 o'clock to
remember the people who've died during
the pandemic and people are being
encouraged to stand on their doorsteps
at 8pm with phones candles and torches
to signify a beacon of remembrance
from today coronavirus restrictions in
wales are beginning to ease
up to four people from two households
are allowed to meet outside
including in private gardens outdoor
sports facilities are also allowed to
reopen
and indoor care home visits by a single
designated visitor are permitted once
again
from monday primary school children can
return to the classroom
along with students who are completing
their qualifications this year
hairdressers and barbers will also be
allowed to take appointments
from monday let's take a look at the
latest
covid 19 figures now and another 6609
new coronavirus cases have been reported
in the latest 24-hour period along with
175 more deaths within 28 days of a
positive test
that takes the total number of people
who've died to 125
343. 23.3 million first doses of a
vaccine have now been given
as the rollout and lockdown measures
continue to reduce
infection levels
the 25th anniversary of the dunblane
massacre will be marked quietly and in
private today
16 school children and a teacher were
killed in 1996 when a gunman opened fire
during a pe lesson
in the town's primary school it led the
uk
to introduce some of the world's
strictest controls on firearms
well professor peter squires who's a
professor in criminology and public
policy at the university of brighton
joins us now
good morning to you um it's a tragic
anniversary at 25 years old people still
remember vividly isn't it absolutely
it was uh an outrageous event and
a national sense of being appalled by
the fact that children could be killed
by what were
licensed weapons that someone had
authorized this
weapon ownership and so the the the
process of reform focused upon the
handguns themselves and
in in in very quick time uh they they
were prohibited
yes and it prompted an almost total ban
on the private ownership
of handguns as you say an immediate
response
unprecedented absolutely yes
um and dunblane was not our first
mass shooting that had been hunger for
nine years earlier um and and very
little was really done
to to address the the misused firearms
so
there was no there was no saying this is
this is a
an outrageous event this is a a
knee-jerk reaction there was there was a
an immediate demand the snowdrop
campaign was very effective in in
mobilizing opinion
and and although the government
established a judicial inquiry
its its compromise po proposals were
very quickly swept away and john mage's
government banned
one set of high caliber guns and then
tony blair
was the election in 1997 tony blair came
in
and new labour banned all guns including
2-2 caliber
and in terms of um europe in other
countries in europe with mass shootings
uh the the response to
a change in laws um we perhaps haven't
seen it elsewhere there have been
studies suggesting that
though these incidents occur that the
change in laws doesn't come about
that swiftly not necessarily um the the
uh a policy scientist stephen herker
working in in
austria did some work looking at what
the factors
were that uh led to change as you say
some
some mass shootings lead to rapid change
others don't at all
and it has to do i think with the
balance of forces in some
in some places the the where there is
widespread participation in shooting and
a strong gun lobby
and maybe lack of interest at the the
sort of senior political levels
um nothing happens but when there is a
groundswell of opinion as in dunblane
when it connects with a political party
particularly when there's an election
coming up and
and the firearms become an election
issue then there's
potential momentum but it doesn't always
happen
and in this country perhaps different to
um countries like
america for instance uh just how easy is
it to get hold of firearms now
in this country very hard um
but the the the banning of handguns is
not a quick fix
you don't have to be a criminologist to
realize that passing the law doesn't
make crime go away
so we we began to see a whole
new set of converted guns reactivated
guns antique guns being recycled
criminally and finding their way into
gang affected communities
so passing a law doesn't doesn't change
anything
necessarily because guns and criminals
will often find a way
and as much as anything it's about being
continually vigilant
in ensuring that there's no slippage or
complacency that the licensing system
remains robust that our borders are
protected against gun trafficking
and new types of guns perhaps coming
through the internet delivered by fast
parcel
service which means they can hardly all
be scanned
um we block all the other loopholes up
to make sure that
safety public safety is preserved
professor peter's squad is there
reminding us that we still
need to be vigilant thank you very much
for speaking to us this morning
time now for a look at the weather with
joe what's it looking like
it's looking better than it would have
looked overnight if it had been light at
the time obviously you know we had quite
a lot of heavy rain overnight
an area of low pressure and that's now
cleared away into the north sea
uh so it is an improvement you may not
think it's much of one
into next week things look a little more
calm and settled let's take a look
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
this is the culprit this area of low
pressure here
now pushing its way away into the north
sea but
as these areas of low pressure do
they're leaving us in this very showery
regime
and if you catch one of these it could
be quite heavy quite squally there could
be the
orbit of hail the odd rumble of thunder
and certainly over northern parts of
england central southern parts of
scotland
these could still be wintry up over the
high ground however the fact that we've
got these strong blustery north-westerly
winds
it does mean that those showers will
move through quite quickly
where you do find one and certainly
through this afternoon central southern
southeastern areas should dry up
now it's not going to be warm by any
stretch 9 or 10 degrees celsius at best
that's 50 degrees fahrenheit and of
course feeling colder in the winds as
well
and those values still lower further
north but
some brightness will be quite pleasant
we see some further showers pushing
their way south eastwards overnight but
it's largely dry to start off with on
sunday morning
possibly a touch of frost down in the
southeast certainly some brightness in
the morning before we see some further
rain coming in from the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
jackie up next good morning good morning
the battle for premier league survival
is getting
tighter by the week newcastle needed a
last gasp equaliser to rescue
what could prove to be a crucial point
last night
lee westwood is proving age doesn't stop
you being a front-runner at the players
championship
we're going to show you how he's
succeeding where rory mcilroy is
not just now and joffrey archer is the
star man as england's cricketers get
back to winning ways
in india
diana magne and i'm skye's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a
volley of rocks troubles have been
pulled up
out and are being used as missiles of
hell at these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check our identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr bonnie
why not committing you fishing does have
the potential
to stymie an enormous economic feel
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment
is changing but the speed at which those
changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just some breaking news to bring you in
regards to that vigil planned for
tonight in memory of sarah everarda
there's been a tweet from
reclaim the streets which they say
they're sorry to confirm
that the clapham vigil scheduled for
tonight is
cancelled they released a statement in
which they've said they've been in
discussions with the metropolitan police
since day one of planning the vigil and
following yesterday's hearing
they continued those discussions and
repeatedly tried to find a way forward
for the event at our meeting yesterday
evening we made many suggestions
including staggering start times
splitting the event into time slots and
several other ideas to accommodate
police concerns as well as asking the
police for their own suggestions
we've made every effort to reach a
positive outcome that applies
proportionality
so that we could find an appropriate
balance between our right as women to
freedom of assembly and
expression with the regulation set out
in covered
regulations we've been very disappointed
that given the many opportunities to
engage with organisers constructively
the metropolitan police have been
unwilling to commit to anything
while we have had positive discussions
with the lambeth officers present
those from scotland yard would not
engage with our suggestions to help
ensure that a legal covert secure vigil
could take place it remains our view
that with the appropriate mutually
agreed measures in place this evening's
vigil on clapham common
would have been safe and in line with
restrictions and safety
regulations however in light of the lack
of constructive engagement from the
metropolitan police
we do not feel that we can in good faith
allow tonight's event to go ahead so
that
breaking news that the vigil planned for
clapham common
has been cancelled
well if you were sleeping and you're
wondering what happened to the players
championship last night their fifth
major
we can tell you and it's one of the old
names who's at the top
of the leaderboard let's have a look
this sports bulletin is brought to you
by vitality
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
is this the future with its rush of air
crunch of gravel and electric wine
extreme e sounds and looks like nothing
else
and is progressive enough and
competitive enough to hook jensen button
as a team owner
button who not so long ago seemed an
electric
skeptic if i'd said to you five years
ago you'd be
racing in an electric series would you
have laughed at me
look at it it's it's so cool it's so
exciting you know this is an electric
vehicle
that has 550 horsepower initially we ran
at 60
power i was thinking it's not very quick
and then we turn up to 100 and
wow the series five rounds will be held
at global sites relevant to climate
change from oil-rich saudi arabia
to a worryingly ever-greener greenland
but to maximise the messaging on global
warming
must the racing be red hot and like the
ecoscience contents running in tandem
easy to follow the format is going to be
really short races
you know our attention span these days
is not great i mean we're doing an
interview here and neither of us are on
our phones which is unusual
we're going to be racing in places
around the world that no one's really
ever
put a foot down on on the sand or on the
dirt so for us it's an amazing
experience
xtremi enjoys relevance to the growing
electric road car market
but unlike formula e a series button
declined to join
avoids unfavorable comparisons with f1
perhaps as a result it's attracted three
f1 world champion owners
with nico rosberg and button's fellow
britain
sir lewis hamilton also signed up
well sebastian loeb is in lewis
hamilton's car so i think
lewis's team is pretty strong and nico
rosberg has a team as well
so it's f1 world champions you know
reuniting
in terms of its purpose format and
presentation
extreme
i'm in i'm in we're all in to kick it
out
partnering to end racism in sport
[Music]
i'm errol mckellar and i've been a
football youth coach and
mentor for over 40 years
we're at the training ground but the
late night youth team
i've been very privileged to work with
some really really fantastic footballers
the likes of
sol campbell ashley cole ledlie king
but when they're passionate and they're
good at what they're doing your job
is not that difficult all you've got to
do is keep enhancing them
working with their dreams if we don't
make them become footballers we make
them become better people
trust these guys right they will get you
nice
thank you guys i wasn't always a
football coach
i started off as a mechanic that was my
day-to-day job
you know everything was fine until i was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
i found out about prostate cancer purely
by accident when my wife sharon was
complaining about me snoring
went to the doctor i picked up a leaflet
from prostate cancer uk
and the young lady said you don't need
to make an appointment this is a simple
blood test that takes less than 10
minutes i get a phone call
could i come in and have a biopsy done
moving on from that i
had a scan the doctor said mr mckellar
your prostate is covered in cancer
if we don't remove your prostate you
could be dead in six months
and i remember sitting in my car
i just burst into tears because i didn't
know what to do next and my wife came in
the car and she said look in all the
years that i've been with you i've never
seen you quit on anything that you've
ever done
she said this cancer has only knocked
you down it hasn't knocked you out
and i took that as an inspiration
so i had the operation to remove the
prostate i had to have
nearly three months of radiotherapy to
get rid of the rest of the cancer
the first day i went back into my garage
a gentleman came in to
have some work done on his car and i
said um when was the last time you had
your prostate checked
and he said what the bleep bleep bleep
as i've got two of my gear box not
working
and i said to him listen i'll give you a
20 discount on the work i'm gonna do on
your car
if you go and get your prostate checked
two weeks later he came back
he had a 25 cancer
in his prostate he said to me look don't
worry about the money
more importantly i think you need to
start raising awareness of this issue
right because i wouldn't have gone and
done this check
had you not said it and he was
the first of 48 guys that walked into my
garage
no different to this that was diagnosed
with prostate cancer
one in eight men suffer prostate cancer
more frighteningly
one in four africa being men suffer
prostate cancer
even in these difficult times we still
have to be vigilant
you bring your car in here for me to mot
every year why are you not looking at
your body in the same way
committed to getting 100 million people
20 more active by 2025
[Music]
at 7 31 you're watching sky news at
breakfast coming up
more than one million people in the uk
have taken part in research
into covert 19 we'll be speaking to a
professor in critical care
about what this means
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to sky news breakfast now
more than one million people have now
taken part in covid research across the
uk
to mark the milestone chief medical
officer chris witte and
nhs england chief executives simon
stevens have released a series of videos
thanking all participants for their
efforts
every single person has helped
contribute to this who's taking part as
a volunteer
and that's allowed us to develop new
treatments to understand the disease
better and to develop
vaccines so huge thank you
goes to everybody the clinical
researchers the research nurses the
entire team across hospitals gp
practices the nhs
who have made this possible
well chair in anastasia and critical
care at imperial college professor
anthony gordon joins
me now good morning to you um would it
be fair to say that the uk
has led the the clinical research into
to covert 19.
i think it has um this um figure now of
more than a million
uh participants in various research
related to covid in the uk
is a phenomenal figure and i think is
world leading and it shows
um just how uh the uk
uh the nhs and the national institute
for health research in the uk
work together to really tackle this uh
new disease
and provide us answers
can you tell us specifically about the
research that's been
undertaken and what it's it's taught us
what we've learned from it
um well there's a variety of research
maybe if i start with what we've been
doing
uh in intensive care the re-map cap
trial has been looking
at treatments to help the sickest
patients uh
to help them get off breathing machines
recover and we've seen
these drugs such as tosoluzumab
serolumab the rheumatoid arthritis
drugs that have helped they're tackling
the inflammation
that this virus causes but the research
also includes
uh the research into the vaccines
um that been rolled out and is now um as
we know
and so many millions of people being
treated hopefully is leading to the end
of lockdown
but also just to understand the virus um
this
is going to be uh with us i think now
forever
and we need to understand it something
none of us had ever seen before and now
we understand so much more so that
hopefully we can still develop
uh new treatments over time so the focus
now
on how to to live with with kovid19 as
you say it's something that that is
going to be here
um forever potentially
yes but it needs to be something that
then we can
live with that we can manage um
that it's still at the moment despite
these advances still a nasty disease for
some people when they become ill and
come into hospital
so we shouldn't think things are over
and there's still a lot of work to
be done but i think if you think back to
where we were a year ago
when none of us knew anything about this
disease
and actually there was very little we
could do for um people in the hospital
we were able to
support them and just hope that they got
better
um that their own body would fight the
virus together
but now we've got these treatments and i
think um
patients are doing better we have more
hope and i think we can get back
soon to a more normal life for the
volunteers that they've taken part can
you explain a little bit
exactly what they they had to undergo to
be part of
the the research potentially for anyone
who who wants to to be involved
yeah and i think that's an important
thing that these are a
million people who volunteered to take
part in research
they've will normally have
been talked to about the study explained
what's involved
and agreed to take part and they've
shared their
information about themselves they may
have
had blood samples taken so that we
understand
uh about the disease and they will also
bring
those who've had treatments will have
been
put into groups some patients have got
one type of drug some have got none some
have
combinations and by following these
patients
they take part in the research over time
we can learn
uh which drugs worked and which ones
didn't
can you tell us how people can get
involved should they wish to
um there's lots of ways um they will
often be contacted
um by different teams and whether it be
through general practice um whether it's
in um the hospital when you're
approached by
uh one of our research nurses for
instance they may speak to you
and i would encourage people to um
listen to what's um available and
consider it
and hopefully take part and agree to
use the information about you so that we
can all learn and this can help
uh patients in the future yes indeed and
we thank those that have taken part
uh so far professor anthony gordon thank
you for speaking to us
three fishermen set out from north wales
just over six weeks ago and have not
been heard from
since a life raft from their boat washed
up in scotland last week
and now their families are raising money
for an expert to try to find them
sadia chowdhury has been to meet
families in conway north wales
endless questions for the families of
three fishermen
who never came home carl mcgrath ross
ballentine and alan minard
were on a fishing trip in late january
what happened to them
and why they never returned is still a
mystery
we actually built the boat annie he
worked hard day and night
carl's mother julie is desperate for
answers
you just sat there day in day out
waiting
for some news and it's horrible it's
just horrible waiting
and you're longing for it you're just
longing for them to say look we found
them
and that's what i'm longing for you know
to get that
so we can put you know we want to put
carl at peace we want to
lay him to rest the families of all
three have sought help from the ocean
recovery expert
who found wreckage of the plane carrying
footballer emiliano sala
they're hoping to raise 75 000 pounds to
pay for the private search
we know times against us um so we
decided to raise the money for this for
this private search with david murns
who's um
been advising us along the way um so we
started
that off two weeks ago we're currently
up to four forty thousand just over
which is absolutely
incredible the families say they can't
start grieving until their boys
come home this is conway key in north
wales and it's from here
that ross carlin allen set sail on board
a boat that carl built with his own
hands
the weather conditions that day were
described as moderate
a perfect day for sailing this video is
from the boat's
maiden voyage the nikola faith a 33-foot
vessel
sailed what's believed to be its final
journey on january 27th
its gps last located it at 6 pm that
evening
the men were last seen at 10 pm by a
friend sailing in the opposite direction
east of conway
in liverpool bay carl waved to him and
nothing seemed out of the ordinary
the alarm was raised the following
morning after the boat failed to return
a search covering hundreds of square
miles off the north wales coast
was eventually called off
then last week the boat's life raft was
found 19 nautical miles from here
in scotland none of the raft's equipment
had been used
the families say life is in limbo as
they wait for answers
the private search is set to begin next
week
their search for closure depends on it
sadia chowdhury sky news in north wales
guide dogs provide an invaluable service
for people with disabilities but could
they make an even bigger
difference while researchers are
undertaking a genetic study
to try to find out how to breed the best
possible guide dog
examining thousands of labrador golden
retriever pups in the process
scientists will take swabs from the dogs
to sequence their dna
in the most in-depth study of canine
genes of its kind
with the aim of getting a better picture
of the link between genetics health
and behavior
let's take a look at the weather now
with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well
it's been a very blustery night a lot of
rain
but much of that has cleared away now
you might not think it because we've got
showers to follow and some of these
could be quite heavy
and squally there may be some hail the
odd rumble of thunder too
could even be wintry over the high
ground of northern england and central
southern scotland
through the course of the day then those
showers continue to pour in from the
northwest the good news is the winds
will be strong enough
to blow them through quite quickly and
certainly through the afternoon there's
a good chance that central southern
southeastern areas
will dry up quite nicely but it will be
breezy and it won't be that warm top
temperatures only around 10
or 11 degrees celsius that's 52 degrees
fahrenheit
further showers move through overnight
but for many it's going to be a dry
night
a long clear spell so a chilly start to
sunday morning and further rain coming
from the west later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
you're watching sky news at breakfast
still to come we'll take you through the
morning's newspapers with the comedian
andrew doyle and the journalist and
broadcaster bedisha
[Music]
i want spain to roll out your coronavare
vaccine passport as soon as possible in
order to restore
tourism um uh and transfer obviously
this is absolutely crucial for the
tourism sector and its industry
however you know i'm a member of the
parliament i fully believe that this
passport
must be european we should avoid the
possibility of having
27 vaccine passwords in the eu in the
european union and this could heavily
damage again the sector and the tourism
in demand for the coming season it's
absolutely important for the federal
guidance as well for the uk tourism that
we expected to come as soon as possible
to the islands
we we hope uh that that the passport
will be signed for other countries
in fact next next week uh 17th of the
next week
uh the president of the european
commission usually vandalia is going to
present
the the project of the european
certificate vaccination i have seen this
common passport
recognize across you eu european union
will have a very positive
impact in restoring mobility and travel
in all the europe
as well as the third countries can be of
course the united kingdom
that the internal borders of the
european uh union remain open
the passport must be absolutely
voluntary and must not restrict the
possibility of travel for those citizens
who have not been vaccinated or because
they don't want to be vaccinated this is
another possibility
the password will allow the mobility to
allow mobility restrictions to
be list for those travelers who have the
vaccine and it will
eliminate quarantines at origin or or
a destination i will replace the
obligation to carry out all tests
it's absolutely important because it
will be very flexible
no mandatory absolutely voluntary and it
will be
a possibility to restart tourism
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that reducing pollution
outside of school
can help stop toxic air getting trapped
in our classrooms
[Music]
saturday will be another day of sunshine
and blustery showers
the showers most frequent for western
areas and for the north of england and
wales
it'll be cold and windy again with gales
for many english and welsh coasts
locally severe in the southwest so once
again
air pollution levels will be at a low
level of one to three across the uk and
island
as the weather remains windy with
showers or longer spells of rain
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
let's take a look at what's making the
headlines in today's papers now with the
comedian andrew doyle and the journalist
and broadcaster
medicia welcome back to you both uh
starting off with this um
quite shocking and worrying story on the
front of of the mail about an incident
that's happened in the raf
yes and you'll see in a moment why there
aren't any pictures on that front page
the daily mail has acquired video
footage of
a really violent and disturbing
seeming initiation right or hazing
ritual that happened at the end of a
training operation in the uk
recently down to the raf and what the
video appears to show is a naked
young recruit being assaulted and
possibly sexually assaulted
by a drunken group of his peers now of
course this incident is shocking and
horrifying in itself because
it points to sexual assault and
violation and violence
but it also keys into a long-standing
campaign run
and led by defense chiefs who were very
committed
to saying to young army recruits and
military recruits look
this is not going to be a place where
you will be assaulted or bullied or
violated
or subject to these hazing and
initiation rituals
and they were very public about that and
about acknowledging that
there had been a history of such events
and they wanted to stamp it out so
i do hope that this doesn't happen again
and this is a wake up call yeah indeed
uh let's move on to
the the times andrew in this story about
a possible increase in statutory sick
pay
yes so this is uh matt hancock has said
that as we're coming out of
uh lockdown he's looking into the
possibility of increasing statutory sick
pay which is currently 95 pounds 85
a week this has actually been resisted
interestingly by the treasury and what
they're saying is that they're concerned
uh that it the cost to employers would
be quite prohibitive
particularly at this moment when
obviously coming out of the pandemic
out of the lockdown and we need to get
back on our feet in terms of the economy
um hancock has actually himself admitted
that he wouldn't be able to live
on the the current rate of statutory
sick pay because it only covers a
quarter of the average
weekly earnings and actually in terms of
um uh the
the developed world we're actually one
of the low we have the lowest uh one of
the lowest rates of statutory sick pay
for those countries that do have
mandatory schemes so this is something
that does need to be uh
addressed and it looks to me as though
this is actually something that has been
a problem for quite a while and it's one
of those things that
that covert has just brought to the fore
uh and it's forced people
now to address it and actually baroness
harding who is the head of
test and trace has also pointed out that
there is a risk
that people are not going to
self-isolate uh and they're not going to
get tested
if they fear that they might uh lose out
on work
and because the statutory rate is so low
uh that isn't an incentive for people to
get tested so actually
this is an issue that affects absolutely
everyone yes indeed um
on to this story heartbreaking story in
the sun uh this is the girls allowed
star sarah harding um
telling her story bedisha heartbreaking
but also
inspiring and very respect worthy so the
girls allowed singer sarah harding has a
new autobiography out called hear me out
and it's been serialized in lots of
places
she pointed out that she had been
diagnosed with having
uh was having breast cancer and she
underwent a mastectomy
she received treatment for that she goes
into a lot of detail about the rigors
and the demands of the treatment
in itself it's not just that you simply
get healed and you feel better
afterwards there's a recovery period
but she also points out that the doctors
have found
further um things to be worried about
they don't know whether that's in her
spine
or in her brain but the point she makes
that i wanted to highlight today is that
she had felt that there was a cyst in
her body and she just thought it was
benign because we were under pandemic
she wanted to be cautious follow the
rules
but actually she's urging people that if
you have pain not to forget that even
though we're under lockdown and pandemic
if there's cause for concern the health
service is still
open and treating people and we can't
let
those ailments and those potential
fatalities and really serious illnesses
mount up simply because we are being
over cautious of course that's a very
very good sentiment
but she points out that she delayed
seeking treatment and delayed seeking
diagnosis precisely because of an
over caution even though her instincts
were very rightly
um telling her something different so
absolutely best of luck to sarah harding
but what she
says about her journey is really is
really very valuable
yeah it's valuable in telling people how
to listen to their bodies
yes and the nhs also urging people to
come forward if they have other
ailments aside from from covert they're
very much open for business as usual
to the telegraph andrew and tell us why
smartphones
could cause us to grind our teeth
yes this is very concerning this is a
new study that has come out of tel aviv
university in israel
and they're claiming that there are in
fact potential physical
uh ramifications for using smartphones
of course we've all heard a lot about
mental health issues in fact facebook
themselves admitted that it can be very
bad
for your mental health and in fact there
was a study in 2019
of 6 000 children that found that those
that use social media all the time are
far more likely to suffer from anxiety
and depression
and and that kind of thing but this
study from tel aviv
actually um looked at two different
types of smartphone
users so one type of smartphone users is
the regular smartphone user with all the
apps and the various social access to
social media
and the other type is what they call
kosher smartphones and the reason it's
called
a kosher smartphone is because members
of the orthodox jewish community
use this and it blocks access to things
like twitter and facebook and instagram
and that kind of thing
for for the purpose of religious
strictures however the study is showing
that those who
use the regular former smartphone are 20
24
of those people experience what they
call teeth grinding
uh as opposed to only six percent who
have the the kosher version of the
smartphones
and it's also associated with jaw ache
and poor sleeping and
actually this doesn't come as a surprise
to me whatsoever a few weeks ago as an
experiment i just deleted
twitter off my phone and uh i was just
so much happier for the week and
and just far better and i only
restricted its use to
when i was at my laptop so i you know
the moral of this story
get off twitter it's not good for you
and other social media forms
as well um just very quickly uh this
story about um
mps expenses but on a different scale
should we say this in the mirror badisha
very quickly
this is going to make you grind your
teeth even more skank of the week award
goes to tory mp royston smith who
visited a lovely food bank serving
people who need food to help their
families
and uh he used his expenses and charged
one pound for his parking expenses
you heard it right just one pound uh
badisha and
andrew see you in an hour's time thank
you still to come on
sky news breakfast we'll keep you up to
date with all the very latest that you
need to know
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
you